I'm a big fan of Indiana Jones
wait you watched the new one yeah I love
the original trilogy
but why are you laughing
yeah I mean I mean we should have taken
hints from Kingdom of the crystal skulls
all right yeah yeah it's somehow worse
than kingdom of the Crystal Skull really
just watch it uh no I've heard it's way
worse though oh really worse it's just
not the problem Indiana Jones Indiana
Jones works because Indiana Jones is
[__] cool yeah yeah he gets the girl
he goes in the cave he gets the treasure
he's got a globetrotting adventure and
then Indiana Jones Stars estimates he's
just a depressed man in a room it's this
it's I there's no spoilers but Indiana
Jones is just depressed he's 80. just
like Harrison Ford in real life he's 80
years old he's in a room going oh the
opening scene of him is flat some people
are playing David Bowie too loud and
he's like
it's like this is not Indiana Jones
where's the adventure this is racist now
racist angry man and like and the
opening they de-age him
I've seen like Star Wars Rogue one yeah
kind of worked for a few characters but
like you do become painfully aware like
it in many ways it's the best part of
the film right because the because the
rest is the audience
if they'd made it in the 90s maybe yeah
yeah um and then the rest is just like
oh I could get the treasure with a lot
of effort it's just like if I did any
other jokes we need to get the treasure
but will they be coming there
it's all about like kicking ass and like
getting the girl and like no I think if
you've got a compelling Story the 80
year old thing could work yeah but it
does but it doesn't yeah is it a bad
film no is it a good film no did you
watch the whale
I haven't watched it but I've only seen
that one scene
yeah where he's like crying I've only
seen that scene I'm pretty sure that's
the only scene in the movie I just I
just wish you'd watch it because I bet
you'd give the funniest review what
would it be Adam's the Brendan Frasier
yeah oh [__] it's just cries on [__]
Skype call me
you can't say that word on it you better
hide that oh you're gonna believe that
well we don't bleeps it yeah
oh dear well yeah I can't recommend it
unfortunately yeah I wasn't gonna watch
it it's better than kingdom because
Kingdom it's just a cluster [__] it
doesn't know what it needs to be and
there's literally Shia LaBeouf Swinging
with monkeys
no it's not it's because you're a monkey
man or whatever did you ever watch um
Shia LaBeouf's like other weird films
like it's weird
Mission Impossible I watched it
out in Japan yeah I watched the at the
premiere where Tom Cruise is supposed to
be but then yeah and uh
yeah so now the premiere was I went to
the premiere how'd you do that oh I
thought it was like Tom Cruise is one
requests
I bought tickets to go watch the
premiere because I thought [__] it I got
nothing bad to do on a Sunday it's good
uh it's a mission possible
Tom Cruise riding off a bridge it's it's
it's it's you know it's exactly what you
think it's going to be full action
threadbare plot but quite fun I was
gonna I will admit I was a little sleepy
because I was like it's like too much
and the villain is kind of dumb right
right do you want me to tell you what
the villain is no I kind of know a
little bit but okay yeah it's kind of
when I introduced it I was like it's AI
yeah yeah I was like okay ai's the bad
guy again okay technology the technology
evil yeah and it's kind of I mean the
stunts were impressive yeah but it kind
of went on like a little too long almost
like two and a half hours yeah I was
like come on you've got Barbie and yeah
I was gonna say you seem like gonna be
uh watching Barbie right
yeah people don't know why that is I
think it's because the release date is
close to the Hiroshima bombing
unfortunately you might be like let's
have a film about the bomb and then the
next steps are awesome is you know yeah
yeah so I do get that um I will come out
there I think in September I don't
forget Japan they do have the movies
like [__] six months after they've
been everywhere else yeah but normally
they had that that's announced ahead of
time yeah it hasn't been announced yet
I'll just watch it in the UK the reviews
for Oppenheimer look good I saw someone
go oh it was great but I had no clue
what anyone was saying just like tenant
right oh great where every Bumble fist
every like Christopher Nolan film it's
great yeah
twice at least just to know what the
[__] saying he's like it's like a
cryptic mystery watching a Christopher
Nolan film yeah because he can't [__]
hear what they're saying
and it's like why I had to watch abroad
in Japan
[Music]
just
make the audio like good because I
remember like
Batman Begins three Dark Knight what was
it called Dark Knight Rises
Bane was what started it literally had
no idea oh my God Bane half the time
what did you say subtitles are great
yeah
when I watched it with subtitles I was
like oh yeah I love that I love that
opening scene on when he's hijacking the
plane he's just like um the guy's like
no way and he's like yeah
I'm like I don't know what he said I
love him he's just so I've been watching
that and I was a bit close because he's
like what's the next step of your master
plan he's like
it's like I remember going because that
sounds so lame
what kind of survivors I know you also
watch seeing or watched silo yeah it's
good yeah I finished it last night start
it's really good I also wanted um Silo
what's Silo so this uh Apple TV show
about uh you just kind of introduced to
this Silo where there's something
forbidden relics so you can't have any
old technology and there's no elevators
and you can only go up this one giant
concrete Silo and everything has to be
within the confines it's big as well as
like two thousand meters is it like an
indie kind of movie
production uh it's pretty good actually
oh yeah pretty interesting last night
the ending is really good to the first
season yeah oh yeah um I watched Apple
have had a good run actually I'm
watching yeah I still haven't watched uh
I really wanted to watch Tetris uh it's
really it's pretty good is it really
good it's really fun yeah Severance
watch Severance Severance is amazing
yeah
okay I haven't seen it I should see if
it's good you guys don't watch it
there's like anything good anything good
you guys are like oh sorry I'm watching
too much uh anime stuff and uh playing
catcher games
like no no I'm really
I've been watching Severance but I
really struggle to get through this
third and fourth season you're talking
about succession uh six uh yeah
all seasons
the opening theme is a banger though
I'd ride around TK listening to it yeah
yeah I've currently finished like two
seasons of succession and the second one
is good the third one it gets a little
bit Yeah Yeah it all feels good again
Brian Cox carries that show he does he's
very much very intimidating started
watching a new show an apple called
hijack with Idris Elba and it's about a
flame being hijacked well a bit like
just doesn't feel believable the
terrorists are really rubbish
there's five people from Essex and it's
like well I was playing mate you better
not [__] do anything and it's just
like it doesn't work you're just like
just sounds silly
not that I'm saying people messages
Terrace is just [__] yeah the Apple TV's
been crushing it it's Tetris good yeah
it's pretty good I really want to watch
it it's quite original it's very fun we
also did uh drops of God as well they
did a adaptation of drugs of course I've
watched that I actually we actually
watched it when we visited Napa Valley I
thought it was pretty good uh you know
me um but you had a wide variety of
opinions just because Sydney is just
like it's not like the manga it's not
it's not like the mangas it's not the
real job it's an adaptation it's not
supposed to be exactly yeah there's like
this romance subplot and then like in
the original manga like the two main the
two Rivals are both guys but in the uh
in the adaptation the main character is
a girl and she has like a romance
subplot I'm like it's like a live-action
yeah it's like oh [__] I thought the
adaptation and was actually really
[__] good uh city was just like it's
not the mug it's it's not the real just
read the Manga just read the Manga and
I'm like I like it time you'll have you
have plenty of trying to catch up
because these Rider strikes will yeah
nothing coming out yeah your TV has been
consistently the best over the last few
years to some extent yeah than HBO do
you guys flicks do you guys remember the
last little Rider strike at all well
yeah it was like it was like when you
back in the day oh I was a kid yeah I'd
watch prison break I'm like why is it
[__] yeah
best Bond film ever and it's just like
oh they gave up
yeah I remember when the first Rider
strike happened it was just like you
know as you know you're a lot younger
and I'm just like
sure that I'm sure people can write
stories even though it's not their job I
don't remember it happening I just
remember it happened that all the TV
shows I liked a certain season would
always be bad yeah and then when you go
online and look it was like the writers
strike happened yeah and that was why 24
was 10 episodes less and I was like oh
this is why writers are important yeah
oh okay I get it it's almost like it's a
qualified
no it's like for me it was weird a song
like Heroes were such a good TV
shows season three I remember watching
season three and this was before this
was back when before like I even had an
inkling of like there there are people
who made TV shows you know you know that
was like the PV uh TV period as well
where it was like lost 24 Prison Break
yeah where it felt like everything was
like whoa and then suddenly every TV
show I was watching got [__] and I was
just like well what's what's going on
you know what why is this happening TV
fell off yeah did you watch uh Black
Mirror oh I did I did what'd you think
[Music]
and there's about I would say there's
one absolutely god-awful [__] should be
a mistake episodes no the one with the
wolf the werewolf oh yeah that was like
the worst episode of Black Mirror ever
uh it was so [__] and the extreme Berry
was whatever the other ones I kind of
liked the True Crime one was okay
because of the Scottish guy he carried
it the Podrick project from Game of
Thrones he was so fast angry Scottish
man he was so good he was really good he
carried the episode I've seen a long
time and then the the Aaron Paul was
okay but it's too long yeah I didn't
like that one too long I thought it was
trying to be a lot cleverer than it was
just like it was it was like I felt like
it tried to do the same kind of like
twist as uh what's what's what's the one
where he's uh like being forced to be a
bank heist there's there's no uh I don't
something don't talk to me and dance
yeah yeah yeah sharp and dance
I feel like you've said that line before
yeah I feel like that episode had a
really good [__] setup and a good
payoff and then I feel like it kind of
tried to do something similar where it's
just like oh we have this set up that it
doesn't end the way you think it's gonna
end and it's just I kind of like the
Satan one that was that was the kind of
fun the acting was pretty fun in that
where the devil was so funny in it the
Devils
imagine the devil is just like a guy
who's Charming with a thick British
accent he's like well you do mate you
gotta go and kill him it's a good night
it's so good he's actually that was a
really [__] good performance it was
like a kind of boring premise with
fantastic acting that maybe not to be
like biased but I feel like whenever the
Black Mirror episode was set in the UK I
was like oh this was gonna be a good one
it's true though they're a bit more
grounded in the UK yeah yeah why that is
I I just feel like a lot of this season
of Black Mirror they there's an
interesting idea there but that
interesting idea could cover like 20
minutes at most you know what I mean the
streamberry one was no yeah I didn't
like your [__] Salma Hayek well that
was like that's not a line that needs to
be okay that was like the tradition
because because Black Mirror is kind of
struggling right because it had this
very Tech focused yeah premise and I
guess now they've explored a lot of
options and everyone else is doing it
right yeah so that's the power black man
inspired so many people to make well
everyone describes stuff as like
mirroresque right we have anything's
dystopian technology I was like oh it's
very black mirror-esque
yeah she's just walking around with the
cameras black mirrors I would also argue
that reality has kind of caught up to
Black mirror as well in some way where a
lot of these out there ideas that
happened when season one started airing
uh reality is kind of caught up and
we've realized oh it's actually happened
just a documentary yeah episode one
where the Prime Minister [__] a pig
yeah
allegedly he was reported David Cameron
did something with a pig
[Music]
in the UK allegedly uh I think there's
there's more ways that you can explore
that feeling of
feeling trapped online with twists and
stuff and feeling like online is kind of
beholden and you're kind of being
trapped by it there's more ways to
explore that I think that they've just
it I feel like it's probably given up I
just feel like it's dumbed down for a
younger audience a little bit Yeah
guys just you know make it a bit more
like you know accessible to younger
people the True Crime one I felt
actually could have been quite good
exploring True Crime and the obsession
of it but I felt like they kind of were
like all right now let's just do a twist
and it's kind of fun there's a sorry
that's fine I was gonna watch it I just
felt like it because True Crime is
actually such a prevalent thing and it's
never been a fun poignant way to talk
about it in a black mirror-esque way
that kind of didn't feel like they're
nailed it didn't make you sit down and
watch true crime documentaries like the
man that killed his entire family I just
I I don't she doesn't make me sit down
makes me like well she doesn't make me
but she's like I'm gonna watch the
documentary about everyone that killed
them I just I just wake up and like
she's she's doing she's doing her makeup
and I'm just like getting ready for the
day and uh his arms were caught off
ground by his dad his legs were cut off
and Timothy found her uh his dead
parents and called 9-1-1 here is the
call and it's just to keep going
[Music]
and I'm [__] side hearing
a report his dead parents
YouTuber that a Charged money to see an
11 year old boy's autops oh yes I did
see that news because I guess True Crime
is going so commodified now yeah what
they had I guess people are like because
obviously I think a lot of the
historical cases have already been well
documented so now it's getting to the
point where they're covering like stuff
as it's happening which is kind of
[__] because like yeah yeah these
people were inserting themselves in like
the process essentially and were like
turning up to the the hearings and
getting the information they're just
immediately posting about it it's like
it's pretty [__] like it's just it's
getting to this state now where like
True Crime is just it's just like a
reality TV show of what's happening and
then now they're showing the [__]
morbid stuff because we have these
systems of accountability where people
would have to release information to the
public and now it's kind of being abused
in a way where it's like turning it into
circus shows and freak shows it's like
if you want the HD photos of a dead body
go to my patreon and pay 15 in dollars
it's like that's fuss so [__] up it's
so funny I mean I mean that's part of
the reason why I was never really into
true crime in the first place yeah it
talks about True Crime before I was
talking about the same time because I
think it's an uncomfortable topic yeah
and you know ever since the first
episode we've talked about it on trash
taste the line has just got and been
pushed more and more yeah and you know
you know going back to Black Mirror I
think part of the reason why Black
Mirror isn't doesn't hit as hard now
it's just because reality is caught up
online is way scarier than when it was
at the first season where in the first
season we can view like the stories of
black mirrors like look at this funny
thing and now we look now we look at the
late season of Black Mirror and we're
like actually reality is [__] weirder
more depressing you know on the next
season there'll be one basically like
ripping off the Apple Pro Vision they'll
just make one her dad who sees this kid
that isn't there and he imagines he's
still there even after the death of his
kid and he goes crazy and it's eternally
fused to his face so he can't take it I
genuinely think like they've become so
shallow that it's so easy to kind of
just write a yeah predict a Black Mirror
episode yeah just hate walking into my
sitting room and hearing when we got
there there was blood everywhere I
couldn't stop the bleeding and what have
you done today in his face and I'm just
like I'm having a nice morning
put the headphones in or something yeah
like the man that murdered his entire
family for seemingly no reason yeah what
no it must have been a reason let's look
at some stuff that's really like you
know they you have that level of
distance but sometimes they show some
stuff or talk about some stuff like this
feels like you shouldn't be allowed to
view a public knowledge yeah this feels
like really [__] feels really invasive
right now yeah